Okay.
One of the big criticisms or concerns or really
fake concerns from concern trolls about the
Donald Trump impeachment inquiry has been
the impeachment in inquiry has not been formalized.
There is no roadmap to what it is that Nancy
Pelosi and Democrats are doing, and as a result,
there is no due process afforded to Donald
Trump.
It's all bogus, but even that talking point
is about to fall apart because the house is
going to be voting on formalizing the roadmap
and the next steps of the Trump impeachment
inquiry, which is an increasingly popular
impeachment inquiry with the American people.
As we've been talking about for the last three
weeks, we anticipate that this is going to
be introduced today.
Maybe it's already been introduced or even
voted on.
By the time you watch this clip or listened
to today's show, will they be uniting under
the umbrella of harassing Donald Trump?
No.
Will they officially announced the start of
a witch hunt?
Give me a break.
This is a formal process which will spell
out the rights that a president has during
an impeachment inquiry.
It will spell out the role that Donald Trump's
attorneys can play and a bunch of other processes.
So what's the real meaning of this?
It is to set up a framework so that Trump
can't or at least would look stupid to continue
insisting that this is a constitutionally
invalid inquiry.
That it's a violation of his due process.
Trump has been pulling these stunts for a
while now and of course they're absurd.
Impeachment inquiries by the house are constitutionally
delineated, nevermind a valid but still formally
authorizing an inquiry with its guideposts
and establishing what due process will look
like is a good thing because we live in the
United States and this is how we do things.
Now.
This is going to pressure Republicans to cooperate.
It's not going to force them to cooperate.
Uh, Congressman RO Khanna friend of the show
yesterday was saying this will further put
pressure on Republicans to just cooperate
with the inquiry.
They may still be in the same place in two
weeks, which is, uh, ignoring subpoenas, ignoring
subpoenas for documents.
And at that point we will go back to what
is very quickly becoming the most prominent.
And sort of foremost issue in this impeachment
inquiry.
Will Democrats at least attempt to enforce
their investigative and subpoena power or
we'll Republicans and Donald Trump get away
with ignoring it all again and again and again.
And ultimately, this is going to be another
point in the process which will simply be
spun by Trump, is Trump ISTs are already saying,
I saw them on Reddit this morning.
Why are all these steps and votes being put
in place?
It seems so forced and consider the absurdity
of this.
First they said, you know, the problem is
this thing is not formal enough.
It's a wacky witch hunt.
There's no limits, it's no holds barred.
And now Democrats want to formalize it and
put some limits and some structure around
it.
And those same Trumpists are saying, Oh, this
is so forest boats delineating exactly what's
the, this is just too much.
It's too forced.
This is why we can't listen to them.
And this is why Democrats just need to do
what they need to do.
The point I'm anxiously awaiting are the public
hearings, the evidence being released the
day after day tweets, storms that no doubt
Donald Trump will be going on the possibility
of, I mean imagine Rudy Giuliani testifying,
but you need to enforce subpoenas.
Yes, Rudy, if you force him to show up, we'll
say, I don't recall to every question he will
say on the advice of counsel, I am invoking
my fifth fifth amendment privilege against
self incrimination or fifth amendment privilege.
He will do all of those things, but you still
need to enforce subpoenas or this entire thing
ends up being just a pathetic waste of time.
Don't make it a waste of time, Democrats.
Please don't make it a waste of time and I,
let me just readdress this point a few people,
even though I'm, I discussed this yesterday,
I still got emails from people saying, David
Democrats can try to enforce subpoenas, but
still nothing might happen.
Okay, well let's cross that bridge when we
come to it.
At least try to enforce the subpoenas by every
legal and law enforcement means that is available
to you to say you're putting the cart before
the horse.
It's a big metaphor day.
You're putting the cart before the horse to
say it doesn't matter if Democrats try to
enforce the subpoenas because Republicans
will get away with ignoring them anyway.
It's different to get away with ignoring them
after Democrats have actually tried to enforce
the subpoenas than merely to say Republicans
got away with ignoring the request and nothing
else happened.
Uh, we are going to be following this.
We will see really how this is all structured
in the vote that Nancy Pelosi plans to put
forward in the house of representatives very,
very soon.
Make sure you're following me on Twitter at
D Pacman, and while you're on Twitter following
me, follow the show at David Pakman show.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this